Apple has always been Infamous for their
high prices and large profit margins
while the rest of the manufacturing
industry has net margins of two to five
percent Apple has net margins of 25
but over the past couple of years
they've taken this to even the next
level of course they've jacked up prices
of iPhones and introduced high margin
services but I'm talking about something
much more profitable I'm talking about
the largest brand placement operation
that has ever taken place if you use an
iPhone Safari and Siri have probably
redirected you to Google it tens of
thousands of times
this probably felt quite natural given
that Google is the most dominant search
engine I mean imagine if Apple had
always redirected you to Bing that would
have felt so wrong but that may have
actually been more likely than you might
think
you see apple didn't choose to integrate
Google just because it was popular or
too disk Microsoft the only reason they
decided to integrate Google was because
they were willing to pay them at first
it was a much more reasonable amount in
2014 it was about a billion dollars but
since then this number hasn't doubled or
tripled or even quintupled it has
straight up grown at 20x to 20 billion
dollars and the best part is that this
is basically 100 profit for Apple for
perspective the iPhone user count has
only grown about 3x during the same time
period so Google is paying over six
times more for each user this is not
only a ridiculous amount to pay for
search engine integration but it's a
ridiculous amount even for apple as a
whole Apple makes between 95 to 100
billion dollars every year so the 20
billion that Google is paying them
literally accounts for 20 of Apple's
entire net profit in other words Apple
could reduce everything else they do to
a break-even operation and it just based
on the royalty from Google they would
boast a valuation of 600 billion dollars
AKA world's 10th largest company and
this massive payment just scratches the
surface of Apple's Mega monetization
plan so join me as we take a look at
Apple's brilliant strategy to outlive
the stagnation of the iPhone
thank you
we all know that Apple's biggest product
is the iPhone and that it's still the
core of their business but do you know
just how dependent they really are well
in the first quarter of this year Apple
pulled in a total of a 94.8 billion
dollars worth of Revenue but out of this
94.8 billion 51 billion was directly
from iPhone sales in other words over
half of Apple's entire Revenue still
comes from selling iPhones this becomes
even worse when you consider that the
rest of the revenue is also linked to
the iPhone sure Apple might have
hundreds of millions of users for iCloud
and apple music and the App Store but
how many of these people would still use
these Services if they didn't have an
iPhone the same thing could be said
about Apple's other physical products as
well how many people buy an Apple Watch
and a Macbook just because they've
already bought it into the Apple
ecosystem so despite being a 3 trillion
dollar company Apple is still like 90
dependent on their hero product the
iPhone this is a massive problem because
iPhone sales peaked way back in 2015
which is somehow almost a decade ago at
this point and that's no wonder why
smartphones have basically reached their
Peak form which makes it less and less
appealing to upgrade with every
iteration but there is a silver lining
to all of this while apple is selling
less iPhones in total the people who do
buy iPhones nowadays tend to be people
who are converting from Android in fact
back in 2016 iPhones only accounted for
33 of smartphone sales in the US but by
the end of 2020 this number had a nearly
doubled to 65 apple is setting records
in China and they just recently started
opening stores in India as well so while
Apple has had a tough time getting
people to upgrade their iPhones they've
actually done really well in terms of
retaining iPhone users and getting
Android users to switch teams so the key
for Apple has very much been to focus on
monetizing existing iPhone users as
opposed to selling more iPhones which
brings us into phase one of Apple's
monetization strategy given that Apple
is very much a hardware company as much
as they are a software company they
start off with launching smartphone
adjacent products this of course
includes smartphone cases the Apple
watch airpods and air tags at first many
of these products got quite a bit of
resistance especially the airpods paying
150 for a pair of wireless headphones
seemed that ludicrous six years ago but
nowadays that's the norm in fact you'd
probably be the odd one out if you were
using wired headphones in public around
the same time Apple also experimented
with pricing they were very much pushing
the boundaries of what people were
willing to pay for iPhones what started
off as a 650 phone Rose to 750 and 800
and a thousand and eventually 1100 which
is where the Pro Mag starts now they've
actually chilled out on raising prices
for five years now but there are rumors
that the iPhone 15 will have a 100 price
increase so this may not last for much
longer no matter how many times Apple
increases iPhone prices though there's
only so much profit that can be made
from Hardware given that you have to pay
for factories and materials and
Logistics and shipping and all of that
software on the other hand is far more
lucrative which brings us into phase two
of Apple's grand plan
Apple has taken a completely different
approach when it comes to software with
Hardware they always position themselves
as the premium brand with the premium
products that came in at a premium price
but with software they've positioned
themselves extremely competitively in
fact in most cases their pricing is
identical to the competition take iCloud
for example Apple charges one dollar for
50 gigabytes two dollars for 200
gigabytes and 10 for 2 terabytes now
guess what Google charges for cloud
storage well their basic plan starts at
100 gigabytes for two dollars which is
the same as one dollar for 50 gigabytes
there they have the same 200 gigabytes
for three dollars and two terabytes for
ten dollars the same thing can be said
about Apple music as well for student
plans Spotify charges five dollars while
Apple charges six dollars for individual
plans Spotify charges ten dollars while
Apple charges eleven dollars
and for family plans Spotify charges 16
while Apple charges 17 dollars till the
end of last year this small one dollar
pricing discrepancy wasn't even a thing
either this has given Apple a pretty
unique Monopoly while there's nothing
fundamentally special about Apple
services in terms of pricing or features
given that their entire brand image has
been built to run premium products
people naturally Associated Apple
services with being Superior even if
they aren't so when the average iPhone
user is choosing between Spotify and
apple music or iCloud and Google Drive
they tend to just go with Apple's
offering this is only propelled by the
fact that Apple's offerings tend to have
better integration with Apple's devices
well for obvious reasons this has
allowed Apple to reach just a ridiculous
number of paid subscribers over 900
million to be exact for perspective even
Netflix only has a total of 232 million
subscribers and getting paid subscribers
is literally their main business for
Apple it's a side quest this number
becomes even crazier when you consider
that there's only 1.36 billion iPhone
users this means that nearly 70 percent
of all iPhone users have some sort of
paid Apple subscription now of course
that isn't exactly true as Apple's most
dedicated user base likely has multiple
Apple subscriptions which skews numbers
but you get the idea apple is killing it
with services and that's just the
obvious Services we can't talk about
Apple services without mentioning the
almighty app store which literally has a
trillion dollar GDP if the Apple App
Store was a country they would have the
16th highest GDP in the world now Apple
doesn't get a commission on most of this
activity as most of it doesn't go
directly through Apple but for the
transactions that do pass through Apple
they collect a solid 15 to 30 percent
which translates to somewhere between 70
and 85 billion dollars and given that
shipping software is magnitudes cheaper
than shipping Hardware this is far more
profitable for Apple than selling
iPhones going back to the first quarter
of 2023 Services only account for about
a fifth of Apple's Revenue in terms of
gross profit however Services accounted
for over a third and this is only
growing by the day before you know it
services will account for over half of
Apple's profit but all of that is
nothing in comparison to Apple's real
money driver which brings us into phase
three
foreign
to Apple's products they often talk
about a Walled Garden for obvious
reasons Apple likes to promote people to
use Apple products over other products
so they tend to make their Integrations
with third-party products substantially
worse than their Integrations with their
own products like iMessage and FaceTime
this has prompted many users to go with
Apple for everything this in itself is a
pretty smart strategy in terms of
getting more customers and increasing
loyalty but it goes much deeper than
just that
all of a sudden the only way to beat
certain people is to go through apple as
they've made it substantially harder for
other companies to track iPhone users
they like to Brand this as a privacy
effort and I'm sure that's part of the
equation but the other part is to get
ultimate control over these users this
is why they're able to demand ridiculous
sums of money like 20 billion from
Google every single year it looks like
they've got something else up their
sleeve as well an ad platform now there
have been rumors about this for several
months but at this point an ad platform
is almost a confirmed fact if you look
up ads on Apple's careers page you get
75 results distinguished engineer ad
platforms engineering manager ad
platforms senior product manager ad
platforms they're not even trying to
hide it they're literally calling it an
app platform themselves and I cannot
understate just how powerful this is
Google and Facebook have literally
managed to build a trillion dollar
companies around it just serving ads and
that that's based on a much more generic
user base apple on the other hand has a
highly concentrated user base of
well-off people because well their
phones cost a lot of money
in fact the median household income of
an iPhone user is 85 000 and that was as
of 2014.
by now this number is likely over a
hundred thousand making iPhone users the
absolute perfect Target for ads and
given that Google and Facebook can't
effectively Market to these people
companies will have to go through apple
and to pay whatever stupid price they
decide to charge and that this is really
the end game for Apple
they've come to the realization that
they'll probably never create a product
that outsells the iPhone
they also won't be escaping iPhone
dependency anytime soon but maybe that's
not such a bad thing especially if
they're able to rethink the monetization
aspect the key is to switch from
depending on iPhone sales to depending
on iPhone usage because well iPhone
sales are going down usage is only going
up that's exactly what they've been
doing with the App Store and their
services and their predatory deals with
the Google and now their ad platform and
given that these Avenues are far more
profitable than selling phones Apple's
income statements are only going to
become more insane as they head towards
becoming a 10 trillion dollar giant
Apple has clearly just decided to
embrace their dependency on the iPhone
but a tech company that has actually
managed to escape their dependency on
their hero product is Microsoft check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]